my name is Anna and I'm working for a
small company called hiring herb and
it's been a topic of conversation for us
for a while especially being a very
small development team and not
necessarily having much budget or
resources to try and even kind of
understand and then deal with what we
needed to do with the gdpr so just
quickly hiring herb we're building a
kind of recruitment marketplace platform
which joins kind of rated and reviews
agencies to employers so there's quite a
lot of data that's kind of processes on
also within our site as well so I joined
as CTO end of last year and I don't know
really what that means yet I guess but
I'm a bit of everything from desktop
support to product development to
WordPress developers my most recent job
title and facilities all sorts of
different things and then there's my
favorite favorite responsibility which
is information security manager as well
so I don't know for those of you
remember me from on the beach I've got
really bad timing when it comes to
compliance issues in this role because I
literally got landed this job title as
well when it was PCI DSS so all the kind
of credit card stuff as well so I just
start here and then my boss goes oh I've
heard of this thing gdpr do you know
what it means I'm like oh no find out
and so that's what we've been doing for
a while okay so what does it stand for
so it's the general data protection
regulation and effectively it's the same
as the Data Protection Act of nineteen
let me just check the date 98 and
effectively there's a lot of similar
kind of principles in there all the
underlying principles are the same now
does anybody know what the principles
are we really take a guess how many do
you reckon there are oh not bad not bad
now this is a this is Q stolen slide
because I'll do my slices of text but
this was a bit more wizzy so stole this
but there's seven principles and six of
them existed previously so making sure
that you know the day it was fair and
lawful that you are holding that you had
a real purpose for the data that you
were holding you know I want a job so
you know it's you know it's reasonable
that I'm holding you know I'm giving my
CV to somebody in there storing it that
you'd keep the minimum amount of data
that you might need for that purpose do
try and keep up to date when you're
processing it that you'd always keep it
confidential and secure and that you'd
limit the forms that you'd keep it in
that would be identifiable but what's
different with the seventh principle is
they've really added some accountability
and liability across the whole spectrum
as well which means that people are
really looking to kind of tighten up on
everything
yeah there's potential fines now and
reputational damage as well that comes
from that so that's why you know we're
getting all these GD priority emails
because people are kind of panicking a
little about it and trying to understand
what do we do what does it what does it
mean so what what does it apply to so
applies to any personal data that can
reasonably identify an individual so all
of these are you know perfect examples
of things that that could include but
one thing that I learn is that it's not
just personal data from a consumer
perspective it's also personal data from
a company or work perspective as well so
my work email address and that's held by
a supplier of us for example would be in
scope for this as well okay so what did
this mean for a hiring hub or at least
for our small small team so we figured
out that there's two main areas where we
had data and that we had to look after
it so we were controllers of our
customer data and that was our agency
and supplier user data our supplier data
and our employee data so that was data
that we actually owned and we had
consent from people either you know
because they worked for us
and to use their NA number four for the
purposes of payroll for example or
through terms of business that agency
had given us their details so that we
could contact them or phone them for the
purposes of the business of engaging in
our kind of services and mainly that
kind of around email phone number
address Nuttall insurance number bank
details those things then we had also
figured out that we were processors for
some data so we didn't own it so an
agency would put four de c.v within our
platform they might put forward some
details for telephone interview on our
platform but we effectively didn't own
that candidate data at all but we had to
ensure that the controller of that data
had consent in order to process that
data on our system as well so that's the
small team we've got four of us and
sorry for my cheesy grin and as you
could tell it was a bit of a last it was
taken today I don't wear that t-shirt
this t-shirt every day so yeah what does
it really mean for us like I mentioned
before we're really small team a really
small budget and like with any kind of
start business you really before you
invest in kind of shoring up and mature
in certain things you probably need to
spend some money making sure that you've
got a viable business and security and
GD people haven't been budgeted for in
our funding at all so so what did we do
so we educated ourselves pretty cheaply
you know we did in although initially I
kind of panicked and we were speaking to
a few consultants about what did it mean
you know twelve hundred pound a day
I thought we couldn't we're gonna find
out a little bit more about this we
don't think that we need to consult in
so I have been to most gdpr events in
Manchester and some other cities
especially if they've got free food and
Andrea I'm definitely there you know
I've read blogs we've kind of beg stole
and borrowed lots of kind of resources
and things from people as well and
really just going to given ourselves a
basic understanding of of what we need
to do and also trying to understand
where our risk points were for the
business this may be comes back to not
stolen but kind of react
a didya GDP our policy pack and I was
actually really helpful I mean it was
it's pretty pretty thick but actually it
helps us understand kind of a benchmark
of where we where we needed to get to
with all our day-to so for example it
had a secure coding policy it had a
patch management policy I had an
encryption policy password policy a
retention and asset management all sorts
of things which gave us a basic
understanding of how we should deal or
deal with some of these things and what
the standards were that we needed to
work towards so that meant we could do a
gap analysis and go right
we're connor here you know and we need
to be here what's all the stuff that we
need to do and then we kind of work with
the business to kind of prioritize what
was important or most important so we
then decided we need to find where all
that data is we knew we had this
customer data account data CV phone
numbers but I guess was like any small
company that's kind of maturing they're
worth you know things in spreadsheets
there were things on people's machines
there was various kind of servers our
live service test servers staging local
machines with copies of databases on
potentially we had a CDN s3 storage we
had our backups we had printouts maybe
looking about the office and making it
sound really bad it's always a data
everywhere but these are the things that
we have to start looking just to make
sure and where is the data and then how
can we make it more secure as well also
logging in analytics was one as well
just to look to make sure that we
weren't holding any day - there - okay
so we found we kind of mapped out all
the data and for us because we're small
company actually a lot of a lot of those
kind of places were locations especially
from a technical perspective
we're from third-party suppliers so you
know our car hosting our email service
even our DevOps kind of operations is
third party so we engaged with them to
help understand if they were moving to
compliance and what they were doing and
actually that was fantastic as helped us
alerts as well learn as well what you do
it oh we know maybe we should do that
that's
so that's really helped then once we'd
found it we really kind of tried to
understand did we really need it was it
important is it just because you know we
haven't had a shirred up retention
policy that we've got quite a lot of
customer data so we actually deleted a
lot of data that we didn't need or we
anonymize what we what we did need to
keep so that was quite I was always an
opportunity as well because I think from
a technical perspective that's made it a
lot easier to manage cost less in
storage and a lot of other things as
well
okay so then we looked up the data that
we have left and we're like who's got
access to it so this back to kind of
passwords was Carl you know we invoke
kind of password password policies or
stronger password policies again being a
small company there'd been this kind of
oh you know I'll just borrow that
password you know a shared password that
was written down printed on the wall
although that might be a safer place to
keep it what were saying here simple
things like making sure that people lock
in their screen creating a bit of a
starter and leave a process even though
there's only you know there was any kind
of nine people when we started the
amount of access that kind of been given
on an ad-hoc basis and then someone
would leave and there would be like few
weeks later they you know they
potentially still got a password to a
live production system ah you know we
need to get process in place to make
sure and that we don't do that again
so that was access to the data and then
anything that's left any other day that
was left looking at making sure that
we're securing it as much as possible so
that's kind of the point we're at at the
minute is looking at improving the equip
ssin our application data but also
making sure that district encryptions on
the on the laptops for users if they've
got anything downloaded yep
and generally kind of continuing to
create processes and assurances as we
kind of grow the code base as well so
looking at em we've got it sorry
you know ongoing vulnerability scanning
regular pen tests using for example
break man in the release pipeline to
make sure that we're continually just
checkpoint in where we are try to
document a little bit more so that when
people are coming in to kind of
understanding how things are working
what we use in and looking at
implementing kind of privacy by design
which is something that gdpr talks about
which is really right with any kind of
new development you're doing kind of
really thinking about that data do you
need it where you going to store it
who's going to access it so that you can
continually make sure that you kind of
keep this up so what's next so really I
think we're going to try and work on how
do we automate a lot of this stuff as we
move forwards I think because a small
company a lot of it is around kind of
process you know it's kind of process
driven we can't afford a kind of
all-singing all-dancing GDP are one kind
of push solution and a lot of it is kind
of workarounds and best endeavors to
make sure that we can follow the
processes so hopefully as we move forth
will be able to automate a lot of that
for the business and help them but just
generally it's never it's never going to
be done it's kind of it's not you get to
the I think it's the 25th of May where
it officially comes in which is why your
emails will be hammered I think even
more so for the next week apologies if
you get one from us but it's just it's
kind of one of those it's those ongoing
processes and it's really important to
kind of bed in and educate people within
your teams to make sure they understand
what they need to do so thank you you
all still wake
[Applause]